[Music]  scp flex  is a different option for the stanford  executive program  instead of coming to stanford for six  immersive weeks in person  you come for two weeks immerse yourself  engage  and then you go back to your home base  and for a period while you're back at  work we  engage in online synchronous delivery of  content  where you're interacting with the  faculty interacting with your other  colleagues in the program  as well as engaging in networking events  and leadership coaching  your job is to come here not because you  know what's next  but because you want to design a  future of discovery beyond your wildest  [Music]  dreams